hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for it is the
second Clash of Yankee and dingler and
this time world championed English and
it is their first game after their world
Chase championship match and this time
uh with ding being in the role of uh of
actual classical world champion so uh if
uh if Nepal wins this one he will cross
2800 for the first time he has the white
pieces and of course he would very much
like revenge for what happened in the
World Chess Championship Match uh so
let's see uh how the game went we have
pawned the form yeah Knight to F6 C4 E6
Knights the C3 and pawn to D5 the
Queen's Gambit declined we have the
exchange variation uh and the best of
the G5 the so-called positional line
c6e3 and already ding goes for some very
exciting Maneuvers with Bishop to F5
which is not um how this is usually
played either people go for Bishop t7 or
they prepare Bishop F5 with with this H6
move point being that now after the best
moves now you play F5 and if a queen F3
now it's not as spectacular because
after everything gets traded off on F6
and Knight F3 you don't have to worry
about Knight H4 because the bishop can
just step back to H7 here in the game
after Bishop to F5 nipple said all right
I'm very much interested in in this we
have Bishop to G6 Bishop captures Queen
captures uh we have Queen captures G
captures and now Knight to F3 but now
ding does not have the H7 Square
available for the bishop but he doesn't
care he just plays Pawn to A5 and okay
nepo says show me what you got he plays
Knight to H4 we have Ponte A4 now going
for Pawn A3 he wants the weekendings
king side sorry Queen side Ponte A3
stopping that and now Knight to D7 Nepal
says all right Ponte F4 let's get that
F5 move in uh and Bishop to C2 now this
is how ding avoids his Bishop getting
trapped with Rook to C1 Bishop to B3 and
now a wonderful move went up on Knights
the B1
uh he wants to go after this bishop on
B3 and it's very interesting to see how
dinga gets out of it uh uh gets out of
it he plays Rook to A5 he wants to get
the C5 move in uh and he wants to do it
as quickly as possible and even get it
to C4 if ding if nepo doesn't trade uh
but ding spent a lot of time here is so
it's very hard to see if this is
something that he actually prepared or
did he mixed up lines again uh and just
had to work his way out of this one
because nepo has some an hour and 10
minutes on the clock whereas dink has
only 43 minutes on the clock and this is
only move 15. so here we have Bishop to
E2 nepo not rushing it with this Knight
to D2 idea because he knows that the
Knight is coming to C3 the bishop is
coming to F3 and the D5 will rather
should be a long-term weakness because
of course C5 is Dean's plan so he does
go for it C5 and just Knights the F5 now
this is a wonderful Square for nipples
Knight here I just uh you know nothing
can oppose him Knight to B6 and now
Knight the E2 you could also still wait
with this idea you could try improving
your position a little bit get the Rook
into the game but okay Knight to D2 goes
after the bishop and now c4 and here
nepo tries Knight back the B1 this was
the idea behind the immediate Knight to
D2 but the ding doesn't care he plays
Knight to A8 and this is again like nepo
found this beautiful move with the
Knight back a knight to B1 uh so finds
ding Knights to A8 and now he's saying
that he doesn't care about this setup
because the Knight on C7 will be nicely
defending the D5 pawn and also B5 B4 is
coming so how can nipple play this uh
here nipple was still some 20 minutes up
on the clock but here he really had to
figure out how to go about this because
uh well he did the
spend a lot of time here and he played
Knight to C3 and at some point I don't
think he was in this position I think it
was maybe when he was playing King to
Knights the B1 uh he he was uh you know
playing the move Knight to B1 and then
he uh knocked down the king with his
jacket and you know it was a a pretty
weird moment because the Oscar said in
the in the live commentary that this
once happened to a player and then he
had to play with the King uh so really
you know uh a weird stuff for someone to
actually expect that but in the end it
worked out very well for him because uh
he actually played the move that he
would never play but it was the move
that won him the game so chess is weird
like that and here we have knighted the
C7 now the move that everyone thought
that Ding would go for a spawn to B5 uh
and now how do you play this and now the
D5 Pawn is unguarded but the problem is
if Knight captures on D5 now you play B4
look at the Knights uh undefended here
Ponte E4 B captures an A3 beat captures
an A3 and Bishop doctors and A3
attacking the rook and C1 Knight
captures and F6 with check King to d8
and now as The Rook is hanging here Rook
captures on C4 you give up the exchange
but it would not be easy to play this I
mean look at those Knights look at the
bishop look at the the beautiful pawns
here the king is coming to E3 The Rook
is coming into the game but ding would
have the outside passed a pawn so it
would definitely be a huge trade-offs
but ding doesn't like it he plays Knight
to C7 first uh prepares B5 with the D5
Pawn being defended and okay King to F2
Pawn to B5 and pawn to E4 we have Pawn
to B4 a capture sunb for Bishop captures
and now we have Knight captures on D5
also a very interesting move was e
characters on D5 I'm going to show you
because it's really a spectacular Bishop
captures B captures on C3 and now Knight
captures on D5 but now Bishop captures
on C4 Bishop captures Knight to D6 with
check this is how you win back material
King to D7 and 9 characters and C4 so
this was also possible with white pretty
much ending up all of these variations
being up upon and if you can get those
pawns out of the board it's going to be
great but ding would always have the
outside past a pawn so nepo decides for
Knight captures on D5 instead Knight
captures e captures on D5 and now Rook
capture Sun D5 and here ding uh will
sort of suffer for for the rest of the
game the move that um I had to be played
here was King the D7 and it's a really
uh weird move to play uh because you can
capture the pawn here and uh if you
don't uh nepo can just play Knight to E3
but the point is uh after Knight the E3
uh you can just play let's say Rook the
B8 and the game continues Knight
captures and C4 you're gonna play real
captors on D5 and still everything is
perfectly fine uh the really tricky line
was if white doesn't go for Knight to E3
and if nipple would play Bishop captures
and C4 then there was this incredibly
tricky Bishop to d2 move attacking The
Rook here and now you would have to play
Bishop capture some B3 Bishop captures
and C1 Rook captures and they captures
on B3 and you would have to play this
being down the exchange but you have a
lot of Pawns here and you have good
chances so it would probably be black
would be struggling here but okay Rook
captures on D5 was played right away by
Ding and now comes the shop captures and
C4 by Nepal now it seems that nepo is
the one that missed the critical line
and that is Pawn to G4 uh the problem is
here Bishop to D2 is met with Bishop
captures and C4 and now if Bishop
captures on C1 Bishop captures on D5
Bishop captures The Rook captures would
be very very uh strong for nipple with
the the thread of Rook Rook coming to
see it you have to play King D7 then the
rule gets very active uh and so on so
this would be good chances for nepo but
he played Bishop captures on C4 right
away Rook captures on F5 and now Bishop
captures on B3 probably thinking that he
will be able to capture the A4 Pawn
after all is said and done but ding says
Nope and he just castles here and this
is a great move because if you capture
here uh you pretty much lose the game
King E3 attacks the rook and now you
don't have a good move there's no
defense because Rook the C8 check is
coming in also The Rook is hanging and
the best he would have is King t7 and
now after King captures an F4 Bishop to
D2 check and after King T4 okay now you
trade captures captures you capture and
B3 and you you try and play it like this
so this would be possible but then you
just played castles and now the problem
is nepo doesn't have Bishop captures on
A4 if he does this then ding had this in
mind Rook captures on F4 and after king
attacks The Rook now Bishop to D2 check
very nasty check defending the Rook
forcing King captures on D2 Rook
captures here with Chuck King says again
to C3 captures on A4 and okay you do get
the push or beep on but the Rook goes um
in front of the pass Pawn equal material
nothing really happening here so instead
after castles nipple forced to find
something else he plays Rook to C4 and
now the players are very low on time now
nipo is now down to nine minutes and the
clock being has some 15 minutes on the
clock and now we have Rook captures on
F4 check King to E3 and Bash up the
detail with check very nicely done or
the bishop will fall so you might as
well move it uh to get the white king to
a lesser active Square King characters a
captures on B3 and now Rook to E1 trying
to get as much activity as possible Rook
to d8 biting going after the d-pawn king
to D3 defending and now Pawn to F5 and
now it's dink was up it's not a dinkles
up a pawn now it's equal material I
think it's not down upon uh and uh well
uh it is a double death Pawn but still
nothing to worry about with a rook to B4
Ponte H5 Rook to E2 and now Pawn to H4
with Pawn to H3 King to G7 King to C3
and now Rook to E4 offering a trade and
the undoublement of the pawns I I doubt
that's a word but um you know let's go
with that King to D3 Rook counters I
need to King characters and King to F6
with King to F3 Rook to G8 going for
some Rook to G3 action if maybe you play
something silly like this so just work
the B6 checking E7 and King to F4 with
Rook captures on G2 Rook captures on B3
and now King 36 Rook to E3 with check
and now it's only a matter of time how
players will agree to a draw
King D5 Rook F3 Rook capture some B2
everything gets traded down King
captures on F5 King captures on D4 broke
it for checking E3 and now Rook the E4
with check king of three and Rook
captures an H4 King to G3 Rook G4
checking captors and now uh the white
king will just go after the pawn here so
Rook delivers check captors captures and
now the best kind of draw a draw by
insufficient material after King
captures on F7 on move 54 the players
agreed to a draw or rather it was a draw
by insufficient material so really a
wild game where it's hard to say what
the ding was doing
um going for of course it's definitely
preparation like if you uh you you might
think okay uh Nepal was winning or
something like that because uh some
weaker engines are you know going
completely crazy about the moves that
Ding is playing uh but I've allowed the
engine to Crunch the numbers to to let's
say a depth of 52 and then the engine
says no it's perfectly fine you can play
this and obviously everything has
something like this prepared for the
wheelchair championship match you can
you know be pretty sure it's been
analyzed up to like the depth 70 or
something like that uh so I I don't
think that it was a plunder it's just
that maybe ding was uh you know looking
for his chances in a really obscure
maybe complicated position uh in the end
it ends in a draw so no 2800 uh after
this game for Nepal but the tournament
is still young both of them could emerge
uh as a 2800 player after after you know
it finishes uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank
you tester Edmond Freeman Evan Percy and
uh Amazon for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon uh
which uh probably you know which game is
coming up next so stay tuned for that
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day